Congratulations on surviving.
The last lecture is on the parol evidence rule.
Today we're going to talk about contractual interpretation in Pacific gas and
electric versus Thomas Trey Edge.
In 1968 California Supreme Court case,
the parties disagreed about the meaning of a provision in a contract.
One side argued that the provision was clear from its plain meaning but the
other side argued that it's that if extrinsic evidence,
uh,
were admitted to aid interpretation,
they were proved the meaning was different.
Defendant Thomas agreed to replace part of Pacific's turbine quote at its own
risk and expense.
Thomas also agreed to indemnified Pacific against any loss,
damage,
expense and liability resulting from injury to property arising out of or in any
way connected with performance unquote.
During the work the turbine cover fell and damage the turbine rotor Pacific
sought indemnification for its cost of repair.
Thomas claimed that the contract only covered damages to third party property
and sought to introduce evidence to prove this interpretation.
The trial court excluded defendants parole evidence and found for the plaintiff
the instant court reversed.
So should the trial court have allowed defendants parole evidence for a to be
admitted for the purpose of establishing the party's intent.
The Supreme Court of California reversed the decision below and held that the
parole evidence was admissible in this case.
The trial court conceded that the provision contained quote the classic language
of a third party indemnity provision unquote,
but nevertheless concluded that the plain language of the provision which
indemnified Pacific against injury to property without explicitly limiting the
clause to third party property required the defendant to compensate Pacific for
damage to Pacific's property.
The Supreme Court decision was written by Chief Justice Roger Trainer who we've
read earlier in the course when we discuss Drennan versus star paving,
justice trainer's decision and Pacific Gas held that the trial court used the
wrong test.
It wrote quote,
the test of admissibility of extrinsic evidence to explain the meaning of a
written instrument is not whether it appears to the court to be playing and
unambiguous on its face,
but whether the offered evidence is relevant to prove a meaning to which the
language of the instrument is reasonably susceptible unquote.
The court then held that the indemnification clause was reasonably susceptible
to the meaning offered by the defendant.
Accordingly,
the court held that the evidence of the that have that meaning offered by the
defendant was admissible and reversed the trial court's judgement
after the decision.
Is it the defendant in Pacific Gas free from liability for damaging Pacific's
turbine rotor?
Not necessarily.
The court held that the defendant was able to introduce parole evidence that the
clause was only meant to Deb nifae damage to third party property because the
clause was reasonably susceptible to this meaning if Henri man,
the evidence is unconvincing,
the defendant may still lose the case.
Judge trainor and Pacific gas would have the trial judge hold a preliminary
hearing to examine the proffered evidence,
whether it be courser performance,
a prior course of dealing trade usage or other circumstances to determine
whether the language of the contract is reasonably susceptible to the meaning
claim to be supported by the evidence it is here.
That evidence is either admitted or excluded put differently.
The only way to know whether there is ambiguity is to first look at the
extrinsic evidence.
If the parties have drafted a clear and complete agreement,
the odds favor exclusion of all but the most compelling extrinsic evidence such
as course of performance indicating how both parties interpreted the term or a
trade usage to which both parties are bound.
Section two 12 of the restatement in comment be takes a position that is
consistent with that expressed by judge trainer.
It is sometimes said that extrinsic evidence can not change the plain meaning of
a writing,
but meaning can almost never be playing except in a context.
Any determination of meaning or ambiguity should only be made in the light of
the relevant evidence of the situation and relations of the parties.
The subject matter of the transaction,
preliminary negotiations and statements made therein usages of trade and the
course of dealings between the parties unquote.
The UCC provides no comprehensive approach to contract interpretation.
However,
as we discussed earlier in connection with the Alyeska case,
UCC to two oh two a provides the terms in an integrated writing may be explained
or supplemented quote by chorus or performance course of dealing or usage of
trade unquote UCC.
Section one three Oh three explicitly encourages the use of these important
extrinsic aids in the interpretation process.
It reads,
quote,
a course of performance or course of dealing between the parties or usage of
trade and the vocation or trade in which they are engaged or which they are or
should be aware is relevant and ascertaining the meaning of the parties
agreement and may give particular meaning to specific terms of the agreement and
may supplement or qualify the terms of the agreement unquote.
The Pacific gas rule is not,
however,
without it's formalist critics,
judge Alex Kosinski,
a prominent judge on the Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals has criticized the rule
in extreme terms in the trident center versus Connecticut General Life Insurance
Company case over three paragraphs.
In that opinion,
judge consists,
judge Kozinski asserted that the rule makes any contract regardless of how
carefully it was negotiated,
susceptible to attack by parole evidence,
including self-serving testimony offered by partisan witnesses.
He questioned whether such an approach is more likely divulge the original
intention of the parties.
Then reliance on seemingly clear words they agreed upon at the time,
unquote.
Further,
he added that the rationale underlying the rule chips away at the foundation of
our legal system because written language is used in statutes used to imprison,
violate,
used to imprison violators,
decrees,
orders by courts and precedents binding lower courts.
If quote words are inadequate to express concepts unquote cause then judge
Kozinski ass.
How can uh,
uh,
legal system so depend on language?
How can we ever find that a criminal statute gave a defendant adequate notice of
what was and was not criminal?
While California adheres to its specific gas rule,
other jurisdictions such as New York take the more formalist plain meaning
approach that a judge Kozinski would prefer.
In,
in 1,990 opinion,
New York's highest court wrote quote of familiar and eminently sensible
proposition of law is that when parties set down their agreement in a clear,
complete document,
they're writing should,
as a rule be enforced according to its terms,
it's well settled that extrinsic and parole evidence is not admissible to create
an ambiguity in a written agreement which is complete and clear and unambiguous
upon its face unquote.
Let's recap.
Today,
we talked about contractual interpretation in many jurisdictions,
extrinsic,
Kevin's may only be introduced to clarify ambiguous language in the contract.
Other jurisdictions such as California,
take a looser approach in California,
even if a contract appears unambiguous on its face,
parties may introduce evidence to Peru to prove a meaning.
If the language of the contract is reasonably susceptible to that,
meaning.